welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Elizabeth Bradley faculty director
for the global health initiative and the
global health Leadership Institute both
of which are at Yale she is also a
professor of public health at Yale's
school of public health professor
Bradley's research focuses on health
delivery systems and quality improvement
and has contributed important findings
about organizational change and quality
of care within the hospital nursing home
and hospice settings she has been
involved with several projects that aim
to strengthen health systems in
international settings including China
Ethiopia Liberia South Africa and the
United Kingdom
today we talk with Professor Bradley
about her new book she wrote with Lauren
Taylor titled the American healthcare
paradox why spending more is getting us
less welcome professor Bradley thank you
so much let's begin with an overview of
your book tell us about it
the book tries to take a new look at
health and health care in the United
States we're trying to understand the
major paradox and problem in our country
which is why is it that we spend more
than any other country in health care
expenditures but our population is no
healthier for it we take a look at what
other countries do we take a look at
some best practices in the United States
and give a bit of a historical analysis
and looking to the future what we might
do better okay and what led you to write
the book I actually think I got the idea
in 2006 when I had a sabbatical at that
time I was developing the very first
course at Yale University for
undergraduates on US healthcare policy I
did an extensive historical analysis to
prepare for teaching that course and
realized 100 hundred and fifty years ago
we really looked at healthcare
differently and it got me thinking we
should be looking at healthcare more
broadly maybe we could actually learn
from our past to understand better what
we might do in our future that got me
going okay and I know you you undertook
extensive research to do the book tell
us about that what did you do yeah
we took a comprehensive approach we used
a lot of different methods a few of them
we used a statistical analysis first to
really understand across the world those
countries that are have different
spending patterns how is it related to
their health outcomes across the world
then we also took a very deep analysis
of the history that created the system
we have and we also looked at the World
Values Survey which is something a great
data source that few people have used it
before that takes a look at how
different countries value healthcare and
other social goods in their countries
differently the last thing we did is we
spent about six months reviewing for
outstanding cases in the United States
that we think really have something that
all of us could learn from and how to
better coordinate their healthcare
services okay so I'd like to get to that
in a minute let's first look at
Scandinavia I know Scandinavia is at the
top of the health care ladder so to
speak in terms of what it's providing to
its people and then you compared it to
what the United States is all about so
what did you find
well first a couple of the facts are in
Scandinavia their infant mortality rates
are about half of what the United States
are there our maternal mortality rates
are six times higher than those in
Scandinavia their life expectancy is
longer than ours and yet we're spending
eighteen percent of our GDP on health
care
they're only spending ten percent of
their GDP on health care Wow how could
this possibly could it be what we found
is the two ways to organize services are
very different in the United States we
actually spend only about 10 percent of
our GDP on social services things that
are like education housing nutrition
employer training only about 10% of our
GDP on that if we go to Scandinavia it's
just the opposite they're spending about
20 percent of their GDP on this so we
have completely different almost
inverted patterns of spending social
dollars to achieve a healthy population
and what we find is the Scandinavian
model which recalibrates how much is
spent on medical care as opposed to how
much is spent on these other social
services
is very critically important to whether
you're going to get good health outcomes
in the whole population okay and now in
terms of some of the programs in the
United States that are doing it
correctly so to speak talk about some of
those models and why they are exemplary
yeah well what's unusual about each of
these models is that they really
coordinate the medical care services
with the social services so they do not
look at a patient only for their
biological determinants of health and
what medicine they need and whether they
need to be in a hospital
they look at it holistically where is
the person living what kind of job do
they have what kind of education are
they getting are they in the training
programs they need to be in and these
these event and these are ways to
coordinate these services we're finding
leads to better outcomes and really less
expensive overall services the ones when
we looked at across a gamut actually
several people have discussed this
happening for low-income patients but we
found examples where this was used for
middle class and high-income patients as
well a holistic view of Health one of
the most interesting I think is in
Oregon in Portland Oregon where it's a
combination of a very tertiary important
high tech hospital with community-based
centers really and they have created
something called C train which is an
interested the community train to be
able to integrate what is really the
medical care system with some of the
other services that keep somebody
healthy such as housing education
nutrition support exercise lifestyle
counseling psychiatric care these things
end up I think being almost useless if
they aren't integrated well it's the
same population and that one is caring
for but you if you only look at the
medical care side you can end up really
missing some important pieces where I am
struggling is how to understand how they
do integrate those social services
because you know I'm familiar with you
know my personal history with the
healthcare system so I'm curious to see
how my experience differs from the
Portland experi
for instance well for instance they have
a joint record so that in fact if you
are receiving any kind of services from
the Community Center this that
information would flow smoothly between
the medical care system and the
community center so for instance let's
say you went to job training and you
were getting counseling on how you might
be just faced a layoff and you are
trying to be counseled into what kind of
job you could get next the if in fact
you also ended up being in the hospital
because your diabetes care wasn't going
right that the people taking care of you
in the hospital would know this person
is actually on the path to getting a new
job this is where she's actually
struggling this is where things are
going better and the result of being
able to integrate across those services
you can plan better you can think hmm
how would I plan the medical care so
that this person really does stay
employed or is in a place where they'll
be able to really get that job that
would be one example but we also see it
in terms of people who are in public
housing or they may be in an educational
system where you begin to integrate what
is the school record with what really is
the healthcare record it's looking at it
that way to understand that much more
than medical care is really what keeps
us healthy I'm wondering against in
Scandinavia it seems like the costs are
flip-flopped and I'm thinking about how
would that relate here in this country
in terms of the costs associated with
having a more holistic approach being
taken it's a great question and we have
to be extremely careful we have to do
this in an American way which means that
I don't think we can spend not even a
dime more but I do believe what we could
think about is having our health care
dollar achieve some of the social aims
that will ultimately save healthcare
dollars in the long run
for instance creating incent incentives
such that our health care dollars could
be spent in ways that think about
improving people's the other
determinants of health both in terms of
job training in terms of Education
housing as we've talked about we today
a hospital itself or physicians
themselves are really incentivized they
are rewarded when the patient stays ill
how do we change that how do we change
that so they are rewarded when the
patient stays healthy that's what we
don't we haven't mastered that thing
right what we need to it seems like it
would be a huge cultural undertaking you
know in order to make that happen no
question and I should be clear about
that in our book the most we can really
think about is changing or adding a
little bit to the public discourse on
this issue we we really need to stop
understanding health as medicine there
are two different things and to start
thinking about health and healthcare as
distinct and how do we stay healthy as a
society each one of us has some ability
for that but also aren't building our
system that way and our book I hope will
add to the discourse I don't think
there's a magic bullet out there if if
we had to try to fix it and with one
kind of thing what would what would you
say was most important the thing right
away is we have to change the dialogue
around this issue
that means the media that means the
President of the United States that
means our hospital administrators that
means you and me we have to change the
dialogue to think that health is a
holistic concept that many things add to
our health and you can't always turn to
the medical environment to make you
healthy is there do you think there is a
dialogue that is starting is there a
trend out there moving in this dress I
really think there is yeah I you know I
think we're close to a tipping point in
some ways when you look at the number of
industries that are starting to pop up
that are going to start to be rewarded
for keeping people healthy I think
people are starting to see the niche
that will make an enormous difference
you know we look at Nike and some of the
things they're doing very innovative
things to try to incentivize people to
run and get some financial benefit from
that that's a way of creating an
industry instead of as our medical care
industry is one that's rewarded when
people stay sick can we create an
industry that is rewarded when people
stay healthy
we're getting there I
hope so thank you very much for being
here with us today and sharing some of
your work my pleasure thank you for more
information about Professor Bradley and
her research please visit our website at
yale.edu backslash Macmillan report be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale